Transcription: Manon Armenoult
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Alors je suppose que dans cette salle,
vous avez tous au moins une fois
mangé des céréales.
Ceux qui mettent le lait
avant les céréales, levez la main.
Vous ne serez pas jugé.
(rire)
Et qui met les céréales avant le lait ?
Pour ceux qui sont intolérants au lactose,
ne vous inquiétez pas,
j’ai une autre question pour vous.
On pourrait passer la soirée
à débattre sur ce sujet :
céréales ou lait,
lait ou céréales ?
Personne n’aurait raison,
personne n’aurait tort.
J’ai envie de vous poser
une deuxième question.
Je vous laisse vous imaginer une journée
dans laquelle
vous avez plein de rendez-vous.
Vous courez partout
et à un moment donné, vous vous dites :
« J’ai faim, je vais aller manger ».
Vous rentrez dans un restaurant
et au moment de vous asseoir,
vous vous apercevez
que vous avez oublié votre portefeuille.
Frustré, vous vous dites :
« Je vais sortir et rentrer. »
et là, une personne vous interpelle
et vous propose de payer votre déjeuner.
Qui accepte dès la première proposition ?
Levez la main.
Ok. (rire)
Et qui accepte après que
la personne ait insisté plusieurs fois ?
Et qui décide de rentrer le ventre vide
et de refuser catégoriquement ?
Ok. (rire)
Là, pareil, comme les céréales,
on pourrait faire un débat.
Certains diront :
« C’est malpoli d’accepter
dès la première proposition. »
D’autres diront :
« Quel est le problème, on me propose !
J’accepte et je n’ai plus faim. »
(rire)
Et une autre personne dira :
« On n’accepte pas l’argent d’un inconnu,
ça ne se fait pas. »
On pourrait  débattre pendant des heures,
mais personne n’aurait raison,
personne n’aurait tort
parce que dès lors où l’on dit
qu’un comportement se fait
ou ne se fait pas,
que quelque chose est accepté ou pas,
cela veut dire qu’il y a une norme.
Et dès qu’on parle de norme,
on parle de culture.
Nous avons tous ici
nos propres modèles culturels
qui sont hérités de notre famille,
de notre éducation,
de l’environnement
dans lequel on évolue
et qui dictent
notre manière de fonctionner.
Nous avons des règles implicites
qui nous dictent
la manière dont on pense le monde,
la manière dont on agit,
et la manière dont on voit tout simplement
le monde qui nous entoure.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez déjà
connu cette situation
dans laquelle vous sentez
que vous avez absolument raison,
mais vous n’arrivez pas à le prouver.
Ça vous est déjà arrivé ? Oui.
Eh bien moi, ça m’est arrivé
quand j’étais étudiante.
J’ai fait une école de commerce
puis un stage humanitaire.
Un peu cliché, je sais, j’assume.
Et pour mon premier stage,
je suis partie le faire au Pérou.
Je suis partie avec six amis d’école
et on travaillait avec une association
qui venait en aide
aux enfants des rues.
Sur place, on travaillait donc
on passait du temps avec ces enfants
et on nous demandait souvent
de quel pays on venait.
Naturellement, on disait :
« On vient de France. »
mais à chaque fois, les enfants
me demandaient avec un regard suspicieux :
« Tú ? (rire)
Tú también eres de Francia ? »
« Toi aussi, tu es française ? »
Et je disais « Claro que sí. »
Et là je sentais
qu’ils ne me croyaient pas vraiment.
Et j’avais beau expliquer l’immigration,
mes parents, la France,
ça ne passait pas.
Vous l’aurez compris,
dans mon groupe, j’étais la seule noire
mais dans certaines écoles de commerce,
à force, on s’y fait.
Et ce que j’ai compris à ce moment-là,
c’est que pour ces enfants péruviens
qui ne connaissent la France
qu’à travers les médias,
tous les Français sont blancs.
Et avoir une Française noire,
ça ne peut pas exister.
Puis il y a d’autres situations
dans lesquelles
on n’arrive pas à comprendre
le comportement de l’autre
et on n’arrive pas
à se faire comprendre.
Et ça, ça m’est arrivé
quand je suis partie au Rwanda.
Quand j’ai eu mon diplôme,
je me suis dit :
« Je vais aller travailler en Afrique. »
Il y a dix ans, travailler en Afrique
n’était pas très sexy,
mais  j’ai trouvé une opportunité
dans un groupe média français
qui voulait s’étendre hors du territoire.
Je suis envoyée au Rwanda
chez un partenaire local
pour développer le business sur place.
Déjà à Paris, on me disait :
« Ah, mais tu vas en Afrique,
ça va être simple pour toi. »
Sous entendu :
entre Africains, on se comprend.
So cliché. (rire)
Ça arrive. (rire)
Et là, pour être honnête aussi,
je suis un peu tombée dans le piège,
car il faut savoir que je suis née
et j’ai grandi en France.
Mes parents sont originaires du Sénégal
et pour ceux qui connaissent ce pays
- ou pas d’ailleurs -,
c’est un pays qu’on appelle
« le pays de la Teranga »
qui veut dire « l’hospitalité ».
Un peuple chaleureux,
très ouvert et extraverti.
Donc moi je me dis
« Je vais au Rwanda,
les Rwandais vont être
ouverts, extravertis. » Logique.
Donc j'arrive sur place.
J’ai 24 ans et je dois manager
une équipe de huit personnes,
composée d’hommes.
Première semaine,
l’hospitalité sénégalaise n’était pas là.
(rire)
Clairement, ils ne m’attendaient pas.
J’espérais qu’on me propose un déj’,
rien ne s’est passé,
et je me suis dit :
« Bon, c’est pas grave. »
Comme j’ai beaucoup d’audace,
deuxième semaine, je prends
le taureau par les cornes
et j’organise une grande réunion
où je convoque tout le monde
et dans laquelle, je me présente,
je présente l’ambition de l’entreprise,
ce qu’on peut faire ensemble,
la feuille de route, etc.
Vous voyez le truc.
J’y vais quand même
avec dynamisme, enthousiasme.
Je donne tout quoi.
Et là… Pokerface.
Les gens me regardent comme ça.
Vous savez, ces moments de gêne,
vous ne savez pas si vous avez cartonné
ou si vous avez fait un bide.
Comme cette blague.
Je ne sais pas si elle passe. (rire)
Il y a un petit moment de gêne.
Je me dis :
« C’est un peu bizarre cette histoire. »
mais plus les semaines avançaient
et plus effectivement, c’était bizarre.
Mes relations avec les gens,
je n’arrivais pas vraiment à cerner
ce qu’ils pensaient de moi.
Ils étaient très réservés,
dans leurs coins,
et parfois je les sentais
même pas collaboratifs en fait.
J’avais l’impression qu’ils me mettaient
des bâtons dans les roues.
Typiquement, pour financer
mes campagnes marketing,
j’avais besoin de récupérer
des chèques à la finance.
Il y avait un processus clair
que je devais suivre,
que je suivais comme une bonne élève.
Mais à chaque fois que j’y allais,
on m’envoyait balader.
Ça prenait du retard
et à la fin, j’avais du retard
sur mes campagnes et sur mes chiffres.
Comme je voulais que ça avance,
je commençais à être frustrée
et à me dire : « Je n’y arrive pas. »
Mais plus je forçais et moins ça passait
et j’étais toute seule en fait,
dans mon coin.
Puis je me suis dit :
« Il faut que tu te gères
sinon on va te renvoyer en France. »
Ce que je ne voulais pas.
et j’ai décidé de demander conseil
autour de moi.
J’ai demandé à des personnes
qui travaillent au Rwanda
avec des Rwandais
de m’expliquer comment ils font
pour embarquer les personnes avec elles.
Et j’ai eu quelques conseils,
certains me disent :
« C’est simple, tu n’as qu’à t’imposer.
Tu t’imposes, ça va aller. »
D’autres me disent :
« Ah, mais ces Africains,
ils sont gentils comme tout
mais faut vraiment tout leur dire. »
À croire que ces personnes avaient zappé
que j’étais aussi africaine.
Et puis d’autres personnes me disent :
« Non mais en fait, c’est simple,
pour travailler avec eux,
il faut les connaître.
C’était plutôt pas mal comme conseil :
connaître les gens avec qui on travaille.
Donc je me suis mise dans une posture
d'apprentissage et d'observation.
D’abord, je me suis entourée de mentors
de différents domaines
qui m’ont aidée à décrypter
et à comprendre
la société rwandaise dans son ensemble.
Et ensuite, j’ai observé.
J’ai juste regardé les gens,
comment ils faisaient et se comportaient.
Je me suis rendue compte
que les Rwandais n’étaient pas réservés,
au contraire, ils adorent parler,
mais ils ont besoin de temps
pour développer leurs idées.
Et en changeant cette posture,
mon équipe que je trouvais réservée,
pas proactive, etc.,
était géniale.
Ils avaient plein d’idées
et de propositions,
on a fait de très belles actions.
Et j’ai appris que je communiquais
comme une “muzungu”
- une “muzungu”, c’est une blanche -,
que j’avais un langage,
un mode de communication trop directif.
Et désormais, quand j’allais à la finance
pour récupérer mes chèques,
je me réservais un créneau de dix minutes
où je parlais de la famille, de la météo,
du match du Barça de la veille,
et en partant, je disais :
« Oh, mais j’oubliais, le chèque »,
et je récupérais mon chèque.
Donc en somme,
j’ai adapté mon comportement aux leurs.
Et ça a marché.
Moi qui me plaignais de ne pas être
invitée aux déjeuners,
j’étais désormais invitée aux mariages,
aux décès, etc. Je n’en pouvais plus.
Et surtout, il y a eu un vrai impact
sur les chiffres, sur le business.
En quelques mois,
on a eu une croissance à deux chiffres
et ça prouve que ça a marché.
Ce que cette expérience m’a appris,
c’est que quand on est face à des gens
qu’on n’arrive pas à embarquer,
avec qui on n’arrive pas vraiment
à créer du lien,
en réalité, nous avons trois options.
Soit on s’impose, soit on se plaint,
ou bien on s’adapte.
S’imposer, c’est assez simple.
On impose notre point de vue.
Il y a un rapport de force
entre un dominant et un dominé.
En réalité,
ça n’avance pas à grand chose.
Se plaindre, c’est se parler à soi-même.
Et je ne pense pas qu’on puisse créer
des relations durables
avec des personnes que l’on critique.
S’adapter demande plus d’efforts, certes,
mais quand on se met
dans cette posture d’apprentissage,
d’accueil et surtout d’écoute,
on augmente nos chances de créer
des relations durables et fortes.
Et cette troisième option fonctionne
parce qu’après le Rwanda,
j’ai travaillé dans une dizaine de pays
pendant six ans
- en Afrique toujours -,
et dès que j’arrivais quelque part,
j’avais un temps d’observation.
Et je peux vous dire que la manière
de me comporter en tant que femme,
la manière de gérer des conflits
ou tout simplement
de donner du feedback
n’étaient pas du tout la même
en Angola, en Afrique australe,
au Nigeria, en Afrique de l’Ouest
ou encore en Éthiopie, à l’Est.
Donc l’adaptation culturelle,
c’est la clé
pour embarquer ces équipes
et réussir collectivement.
Il y a un peu plus de trois ans,
juste avant le Covid,
je suis rentrée à Paris
après ce long périple à l’international,
et je me posais des questions en me disant
que j’aimerais changer de métier.
Et je réfléchissais à tout ça,
à tous ces apprentissages, ces expériences
et surtout à mon envie de créer du lien
entre des gens qui ne se ressemblent pas
et leur faire créer de la valeur ensemble.
Et j'ai pensé à un écosystème.
Un écosystème qu’on connaît tous,
qui fonctionne comme une mini société
composée de personnes aux diversités
sociales, cognitives,
culturelles, de genres et d’âges
et qui doivent travailler ensemble
pour produire du résultat.
Cet écosystème, c'est l'entreprise.
L’entreprise, on le sait aujourd’hui
avec tout le contexte
de la guerre des talents,
et de la quête de sens,
du travail hybride, etc,
sont face à une difficulté à retenir
et à engager leurs talents.
Et moi je suis persuadée que pour cultiver
ce sentiment d’appartenance,
cela passe par la culture.
Qu’est-ce qu’une culture d’entreprise ?
C’est l’ensemble des éléments,
très explicites,
qui définissent l’identité,
l’esprit, les valeurs
et les comportements d’une entreprise
et qui la rendent singulière
dans son secteur.
Vous allez me dire :
« Comment crée-t-on cette culture ?
Comment la formalise-t-on ?
Comment la fait-on vivre ? »
Parmi les dirigeants que j’accompagne,
j’observe trois types de comportements :
il y a ceux qui imposent,
ceux qui se plaignent.
et ceux qui s’adaptent.
Les dirigeants qui s’imposent sont souvent
très déconnectés de la réalité.
Celle de leur entreprise.
Qui ont une vision fantasmée
de leur culture et qui se disent :
« Non mais ça marche,
on est bienveillants, nous. »
Vous en avez en tête ?
Mais cela ne fonctionne pas
parce que la culture n’est pas incarnée.
Puis il y a les dirigeants qui se disent :
« Oh, mais cette génération...
Ils veulent de la facilité,
ils sont feignants,
leur équilibre vie personnelle passe
avant le travail. Où va-t-on ? »
Ok. Mais pendant ce temps,
leur turn-over continue d’augmenter.
Ce qu’il faut comprendre,
c’est que la culture d’entreprise,
elle ne se décrète pas.
C'est quelque chose qui se vit.
Elle est surtout façonnée
par les collaborateurs qui la composent.
Mais certains dirigeants ont compris
qu'ils avaient le pouvoir de l'influencer.
Comment ?
En s’adaptant à leurs collaborateurs,
en les questionnant, en les impliquant
dans cette vision commune
qui est celle de la culture.
Parce qu’en réalité,
créer une culture d’entreprise,
c’est combler l’écart
entre l’intention qu’ont les dirigeants
et la perception
qu’ont les collaborateurs de l’entreprise.
Et c’est comme ça qu’ils arrivent à créer
une promesse culturelle forte
et à créer un climat de confiance
où chacun se sent libre d’être lui-même.
Pour collaborer,
s’engager,
et in fine, performer.
D’ailleurs, il y a une étude
de l’université de Harvard
qui dit qu’une entreprise
qui a une culture forte
augmenterait  ses revenus
quatre fois plus vite.
Donc,
je suis persuadée
que l’entreprise de demain
sera celle qui sera capable
de se remettre en question,
d’apprendre de ses collaborateurs,
de s’adapter afin de créer une culture
qui allie performance et bien-être.
Quand on parle du monde de demain,
on pense souvent
à l’intelligence artificielle, à Chat GPT,
à toute cette technologie incroyable,
et je pense que plus ces technologies
vont se développer
et plus on aura besoin de l’humain.
Et si, vous ici, vous voulez créer
des liens forts,
durables et surtout authentiques,
quel que soit le relationnel :
que ce soit avec vos collègues,
dans votre couple ou même ce soir
avec votre voisin de table,
posez-vous la question.
Dans chacune de vos interactions,
est-ce que vous êtes en train
d’imposer votre point de vue ?
Est-ce que vous êtes en train
de vous plaindre ?
Ou est-ce que vous faites l’effort
de faire un pas de côté
et de vous adapter ?
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)